[Music]
let's wrap it this hour with something
cool we came across this is what I'm
[Music]
liking it can be very hard to break into
the entertainment industry when you
don't grow up with much money or
networking wise you don't know people in
the business uh that's why 30 years ago
a California woman launched a nonprofit
to close the gap between young people
living in poverty and established
artists what started out is helping out
10 kids in Venice Beach in the first
year now helps hundreds annually we have
her on the line right now along with one
of the apprentices from Venice Arts
let's everybody say hello to Lynn and
Maya watching on NBC Los
Angeles hi
ladies hey hello hello to you well thank
hi thank you so much for joining us so
explain the program so we are a media
arts education organization and the
program that Maya is involved in is our
Center for Creative Workforce Equity we
work with lowincome young people as
young as 16 up to the age of 25 for um
with priority for young people who are
historically left out of opportunities
to develop their own creativity and to
follow their career aspirations and
dreams um for example we work with young
people who have been uh homeless in the
Foster system lgbtq Youth and and many
others and we really try to foster a
connection between their aspirations and
the education available to them and
training
opportunities um and one wonderful thing
that we were able to do which Maya was
engaged in was to partner with your
parent company
mbcu um on an apprentice program where
we create created a PSA for the
incredible International bird rescue
they're nonprofit organization using
content from the really hilarious new
film uh Migration by illumination
entertainment uh which was um voiced by
El Roker so which was really
great and through that project three of
our students were able to work as
apprentices uh director producer editor
and uh
cinematographer and that's the project
that may that's incredible so Maya what
has the experience been like for you how
has it helped um it was awesome being
able to work with creatives at this
level was an amazing opportunity for me
um after college I joined Venice arts
and I was a part of their editing
apprenticeship program so through that
program they were able to put me onto
this project with nbcu and ibr to create
uh the PSA for migration so through that
I was able to Shadow different people
working on the project I was able to go
to the ibr facilities and see the work
that they do firsthand and then also
just being on the creative end of it all
was so much fun um being able to learn
how to develop a PS say was such an a
learning experience for me so I'm so
grateful to have been a part of this
project and seeing all our hard work
being showcased on the big screen was
just an amazing opportunity for me and
I'm so incredibly grateful for Venice
arts and for Lynn for uh being able to
to put me on to this project absolutely
super cool man it's a big project to I
jump in on that's awesome well thank you
so much Lynn and Maya for your time and
thank you so much for this organization
it's incredible liking your post right
now right thank you you and that's not
all our season long partner pilot pin
makers of friction the goto erasable pin
of the Kelly Clarkson show want to
celebrate those creating fearlessly just
like y'all so they're giving Venice Arts
$1,000 how's that
sound absolutely thank you so much
ladies and before we go I want to remind
you to watch the Cincinnati Bangals take
on the Pittsburgh Steelers tomorrow
coverage starts at 300 p.m. e on NBC on
peock followed by the Buffalo Bills
visiting the Los Angeles Chargers at
7:30 Watch Out b island is good it's
exclusively on peacock I love football
thank you to all our guests this hour
Danny Dita Lauren dagel Maggie every one
of the person at the table Michelle MCC
and all our friends and partners at w
youall have a great day and if it's not
[Music]
changing
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home